[Music]
Why can't we demand the
same level of financial security as we
demand nuclear security, even though the
risks are still
[Music]
significant? Good morning, gentlemen. We have
decided
to hold this meeting to discuss the
United States, and more specifically,
the
American economy. We have
Hervé de Carnois at our table, who will now
speak. Hervé, what can you
tell us about the main
American economic indicators? Their accuracy,
their reliability? Do they
actually convey
correct or incorrect information? What do you
think? The American economy is experiencing
slight growth,
partly renewing its
internal power
through a very
[Music]
significant level of inventiveness. And it's a market of 310
million people with three pillars
of power. The first pillar is
the military, the second is
finance, and the third is
technology. They
are closely linked. So, will
the American economy
continue with weak growth?  I
would say it's likely, and their
main handicap is finance.
Phipéch, what can you
tell us about this American growth,
Estelle Scine? On what basis has
this growth been
founded since 2009? It's clear that the
massive and successive injections from the
Fed have certainly contributed to a
form of stimulus, but a somewhat
indirect one, since it's actually through government
spending made
possible by printing money.
So, we'll say it's not
autonomous growth. Since 2010, there's been a very
clear increase in the
production
of unconventional energy, what we
call the famous
shale gas, which ensures relative
independence, or at least allows
the United States to make
significant
savings in terms of
foreign trade, so no waste of
resources. So, we'll say that this is
growth through
induced economies. As for the rest, well, indeed,
between finance, the
arms lobby, and I would add
the powerful
Hollywood machine, since
audio rights represent
something quite significant in the
United States.  We
effectively have, let's say,
three and a half pillars to support
growth—and I want to emphasize this, I think
Olivier will certainly say something about it—
growth that isn't
creating jobs at all. Olivier de la Marche,
today we're in a
system where, roughly, you need about six
dollars of debt to generate one dollar of
GDP. So, I don't get
the impression that this is a
sustainable system in the medium and long
term.
You're dealing with something that is,
I would say, solely
state-run. Between
1998 and 2008, American households were accumulating
$1 trillion in debt per year. Well, in 2008, that was the end
of it. They stopped because they were
over-indebted and they started
evicting them from their homes, their cars, and so
on. So, that was the
end of it. What happened?
Well, the state took over.
of that, and which has become heavily
indebted in the space of 4 or 5 years, so, uh, at a
rate of approximately 1
trillion dollars per year,
so you're talking about something where
every single dollar of GDP is made up of
government debt, so I think
it won't go very far like this.
Olivier Beruer, I'd like your
position on
Jeanette Kellen's new stance on Quantitative
Easing. What can you
tell us about it? Well, we understand that
quantitative easing will obviously
continue. The United States is, in any case,
through the FEA (Federal Economic Federation), in a near
impossibility of stopping
quantitative easing. We know that as soon as
they pull the plug, you'll have enormous shocks
on the stock market. There will be
major consequences for
financial companies. To get back to the
GDP part, well, as Olivier said, these
last three years it's 500
billion in growth, it's 3 trillion in...
Debts, therefore a return that is
not very interesting at the very least.
Second axis, this is perhaps highlighted from
the work of Emmanuel 16 who looks quite
closely at what is happening on
the inequalities in the United States. In the United States,
additional growth in
recent years means in return an
increase in purchasing power, an
increase in wages, this is the
counterpart of this growth. He
looked at what fraction of
the increase over the last 3 years, all of which was
newly created, was captured by
the richest 1% in the United States and
he arrived at this rather amusing figure
of 120%.  In other words, the richest 1%
has captured all the wealth that has been
created and, on top of that, has continued to siphon off
the wealth and
income of the poorest 99%.
This simply means that in the
United States, 99% of the population has been
in recession since
2009, while the 1% is doing much better. Indeed,
when you average
all of this from a distance, you might say, "Well, yes, it's growing
a little," but it's as if,
in terms of imagery, you were saying there's
fabulous growth in Washington while the
rest of the country is in recession.
And on average, yes, on average it's still
positive because the weight captured
by the 1% is phenomenal in the
United States;
it's
undeniable. How can Americans
see wealth disparities
multiplying
considerably? They accept it, right? They
accept it. And what do these Americans do? Do they
invest abroad?
No, very little. Do they make...
Many donations have multiplied sixfold in the last
ten years. Do they
invest cautiously in their own country?
They make investments, but are they
concerned about job creation? Very
little. Do they want to pursue
new patents and
inventions? Generally speaking,
if you want to invest well, you
need an investor and you need a
bank, you need something else, of course.
But the banking system remains
fragile, not very
entrepreneurial,
and so the image that emerges from
all this is a mixed one.
Hervé, I'd like to follow up again.
Can you tell us about the
American unemployment figures? How
are they calculated? What is the
veracity of these figures? When we
look at the FBOR (Federal Bureau of Labor Statistics) and the
methodology used, we realize that
almost 1 million unemployed people have been
removed from the lists. This has an impact on
the last
quarter. Thank you, Hervé. Hervé, what
can you tell us about this? That
the Americans, as
always, prioritize image over substance.
All sectors, you know, I mean
it's a trend of the last 50
years. So, they present
as positive an image as possible of
their unemployment, which is around 7.6%, whereas
10 years ago it was around
4.5 to 5%, so it has
deteriorated. Americans are
facing a dilemma they can't seem to
solve, and that dilemma is how do
we increase the wealth being created
and employment? But currently, in
industry and services, the
wealth being created isn't
generating
jobs. Mr. de la Marche,
could you give us a little
more of the unemployment figures? And
then, Mr. Béchad,
could you talk to us about municipal bonds
and student debt? Olivier, I have
bad news for Mr.
Bernard: buying back bonds doesn't
lower
unemployment. He believed it for a
while, or rather, he pretended to believe it,
but apart from the trader you're going to...
Hiring someone to press the button... I don't
see who else could be hired
to lower unemployment. We
have American unemployment figures,
we have all the statistics.
That's the advantage of the United States; you don't
have them in Europe, for example, where
you're also given a figure that's far
from reality, except you don't have
the means to verify it. In the United States,
you have the means to verify it, and
it's quite easy. The
statistics are quite well done. So
today, if we recalculate things
with the average labor force
participation rate in the
United States, you arrive at
figures that are, broadly speaking,
the component that they call U6,
broadly speaking, that is to say, people who have
completely left the workforce, people who
are receiving benefits, and so on. You're
around 18 to 19% unemployment
in the United States. That's one in
five Americans. Obviously, you
can corroborate this figure by the number
of Americans who are on welfare.
You have roughly one...  A little
less than 50 million, so that's a little
less than
15% of the population.
So you're in a
country that, by definition, cannot
create value, create
GDP, except through debt, and
except through government debt.
So I would say now there are
really no more questions to answer.
You have companies that
continue to lay off people; there are
announcements almost every day.
Why? Well, because they're trying to
maintain margins while their revenues are
falling. So it
will stop at some point, we know that,
because once you have the
president and the CEO left in the company, it's a bit short-lived. So it will stop at some point,
but it
will stop with a high rate that won't
decrease;
in any case, we'll never see those
rates again.  Before, that is to say, the
full employment rate which was around 4% in the
United States, you won't find that again,
Philippe. Municipal bonds,
student debt... so I'll start, indeed, perhaps
with
student debt, which allows us to pick up on what
Queivier just said. So we have a
labor market that isn't becoming more fluid in the United
States,
naturally, since companies
are reluctant to
hire, knowing full
well that the
natural market opportunities, at least for
consumers in the United States, are currently
almost
locked down, sequestered,
sequestered. So a job market that isn't
opening up to
young people, obviously, that makes things
complicated. What are young people doing
today? They're extending the length of their
studies. Now, let's say that the
norm has become a Master's degree, whereas
when you had a Bachelor's or
Master's degree, you could easily find a
job. You could still go further,
but you had to have the means. Does this
represent a risk for banks
that this market of future students won't  They ca
n't find work and can't
repay, roughly what
volume of debt does that represent? Student debt is
1.3 trillion to my knowledge, but
the banks risk
absolutely nothing since the
special feature of pre-student loans is that they
are actually guaranteed by the state.
But it's inevitable that sooner or
later someone will foot the bill.
Now, what we call the potential default rate on pre-student loans is
officially 12.5%, but it's actually
20%, or 20%, or 25%. So, 25%, 2.3
trillion. Okay, let's calculate roughly that,
it will be 250 billion, the
state's burden. We'll have to find this 250
billion; it doesn't exist, so we'll have to find a way around it. As
for munibonds, we
recently witnessed, in
mid-November, one or two rather
unusual days while
Ms. Yelen was having her hearing before
the US Senate. And during this...  At
that time, the banks—I imagine the
major investors, the families—were
massively liquidating
municipal bonds, so massively that it was
almost historic. We hadn't seen
such waves of liquidations since
the fall of 2008. What this means is that
after
Detroit, Cleveland, Acron, and so many
other municipalities and counties in the
industrial Northeast of the United States, we
realize that there are also many
bankrupt municipalities in
California, as well as in
South Carolina, pretty much everywhere. And
there too, we see that the situation is not
improving, for reasons we've
already mentioned. That is to say, since we
have 18 to 19% of Americans unemployed, the
municipalities are still doing their
best, obviously, to provide some
support, which costs money. And the second
thing is that taxes aren't coming in
because people who have been evicted
from their homes or their cars, as has
been said, these people are also not in a position
to...  Paying neither
local taxes nor local duties, uh,
the tax base, the base of
taxable people, is shrinking, those who remain
are squeezed much more,
even unbearably, so
they end up leaving the city and
going elsewhere. So we have a kind
of spiral here, and I really don't see how we
can get out of it. On the other hand,
if the municipalities go
bankrupt, obviously the State will bail them out
with what? With freshly
printed money. Olivier, uh, yeah, I'd like to
comment on the employment aspect. It's
really interesting what's happening
there in the United States.
Uh, when we look at it clearly,
the number of unemployed has decreased. There are
fewer unemployed in the United States. Now,
what is an unemployed person? An unemployed person is
someone who obviously doesn't work
and declares they want to work, and that
population has decreased. On the other hand, what
has exploded is the number of
people who have left the labor force. The labor force
is the people who
say, well, where I work, where I
would like to work. Uh, and that's the
figure that you  As you mentioned earlier, we noticed
that
last month 1 million people
left the workforce, and when
you look at it, these are people who say, "
I'm giving up, I won't find a
job because I'm
employable, because there's nothing
nearby, because I've been looking for two years, so, well, I'm giving up."
And when you look at that
million, the statistics are
really very well done in the United States.
It's true, we've really moved beyond that in France... well, it's a bit
laborious, but
when you look, you realize that roughly
half of them were
over 65. Because there's a
particularity in the United States: a
lot of older people work. You
have 10-15% of those over 70
working, half of them older, but
also half of them are between 30 and 55
years old, and within that group, there are as many men
as women. We might have thought that while there are still a lot of
women who work, there are also quite a
lot of them.  Nearly 300,000 American
men of truly middle age have left
the workforce, so obviously
this completely undermines the notion of the
unemployment rate. Here too, it's important to
know that the unemployment rate is
the number of unemployed people divided by the
labor force, not the
total population. I'm going to ask a
somewhat
subversive question: this interpretation is flawed. Do
you think this is
misinformation to maintain a veneer
for investors, or to keep
a worm in the ground? Yes, perhaps a little, but ultimately, it's simply
reality. People are giving up, and
the indicator you're looking at—
unemployment—isn't impacted by
people leaving the
workforce. The correct indicator to see what's
happening with employment in the United States
is provided in the same way by the
U.S. Bureau of Statistics.
You look at the ratio of the
employed population to the
total population, and there you have a
dramatic and constant decline since
2009 without the slightest recovery. Or you
look at the participation rate, which in other words,
what percentage
of Americans want to work?  Entering the
workforce, and there too, there's a
very significant drop that's
absolutely not linked to
demographic issues, as is sometimes said.
Not at all. You see this in every
age group. So it's really the
capacity to create jobs in the
United States that's weakening
terribly.
Hervé, yes, everything you're saying is
correct. And then there's the
domestic renewal of the United States, right? The
domestic renewal of the United States is
a series of thousands
of initiatives to redevelop
local activities. There were
8,000 farmers' markets today; there were
4,000 ten years ago. In other
words, Americans are starting to produce
food, services, and
education locally again. Why? Because they've
seen numerous studies that have
been published saying that when,
for example, a large retailer opens a
supermarket in a
town, 13% of the spending remains
local, whereas when locals
decide to create something...  52% of
the money stays locally, so this
movement is developing
massively, and it's not visible
in the major newspapers or elsewhere.
But there are also interesting indications about this movement,
and
as we see in the United States, it's one
thing and its opposite: they decline
in some areas, they
recover in
others. There's something else interesting
too, still in the same
source, the
American labor statistics. You look at the
job creation side, and there's a
little something there too. They announce a
major publicity boost that resulted in 200,000 new
jobs last time, and
that it's fabulous, proving that
employment is taking off. Well, first of all, there's
no job creation, or
very little, in what we all call the
reindustrialization of America.
Not a single manufacturing job has been
created. And if you look at the
majority of these 200,000
supposedly created jobs, you have  A
large part of it is in leisure activities. I'm talking about what
I once called
bartenders and waiters on BFM.
The vast majority of them are paid
very little,
generally earning
less than $20,000 per
year. So, with less than
$20,000 a year, you can't do much, you know.
You're practically unemployed, let's
say. And then,
looking at the figures by
age group since 2008, what's quite
amusing is that it's not the
20-55 age group where the
return to work began, but rather
people over 55 who were
hired. So, over 55,
with a waiter job, you're
not going to get very far, and you shouldn't
count on that for a
real recovery in the American GDP. So,
I want to...  Although there are initiatives here
and there to, uh, create
local markets and so on, but
resisting the crisis, for now we're trying
to cling to what we
can. Also, Philip, I have a
question about American debt: who
buys it, who holds it, what
proportion by country? What
can you tell us about it? I don't have a
poster with the
precise figures, but from
memory, let's say the first
creditor of the United States—ah, well, that's
the United States. Then the
second, of course, is China with 2200
or 2300 billion, Japan with 2000
billion, roughly.
Then we find the
oil monarchies. So there we must be around Dell,
always buying the
oil monarchies, yes, by force of circumstance,
since they continue to rake in
petrodollars despite everything. Even if the
United States starts liquidating its
gas massively, they still have some.
We have the United Kingdom, which I think
must hold some  Something like that, 50
billion, and then after that we have a large
European country that's also full of
bronze, it's Luxembourg, so there you go.
But that's explained because
Luxembourg has a vocation as a
wealth manager, so many
family offices, in addition to their presence in
Singapore, the City of London, Bermuda, and
Dubai, often also have a little
something in Europe to be in the
Eurozone, and so Luxembourg
finds itself a major holder. But what we need to
see is the
dynamics of ownership, and right now there's
one holder that's progressing
at a dizzying speed, which is
naturally the United States
itself, with a Fed that's buying back 77
% of 10-year bonds, and I
think it's 100% for 30-year maturities. So,
Olivier, I'd like to have your point of
view on Aubamaker and
Kestone.
Hervé Aubamaker
illustrates that the United States has a
president not inclined to go into the
finer details of implementation; he has
a strategy, and Napoleon said that the
Strategy is an art of
implementation, so we'll say that the president
might not be the greatest strategist
because he didn't choose the men or
women, and in the case of Auamaker,
it's a woman who is capable, in the
finest legal, fiscal,
organizational, and communication details, of
implementing an extremely ambitious program.
Therefore, the gap between the amount of
spending he wanted to incur and
the actual achievement is unprecedented in the United States, to
my knowledge. And the
IT failure of the implementation is still
quite lamentable in the land of
Google and Microsoft. So, of course,
how does Kstone, the pipeline to transport
hydrocarbons, what is it? It's
very... it's... of course, the
United States does that. The reality is
that the
United States, having now roughly
covered its oil needs, is positioning itself...
what is the strategy of the
United States? It remains a strategy of
global power. We can say they have
less, they have more, but the
reality is there, and so they are doing what
the British did at the end of the...  In the 19th and
early 20th centuries, since they no
longer had the industrial power they once
possessed, but still had the raw materials, including
agricultural raw materials, they
positioned themselves to remain at the center of
globalization. They positioned themselves very well in
everything related to distribution and collection. Yes,
we can indeed talk about this
flash in the pan regarding energy in the
United States. And are
you referring to the
New York Times document, those 400
pages of emails leaked by the New York
Times, where industrial professionals
raise warnings, saying, "
Beware, shale gas may be a
bubble. Shale gas has a high rate of
decay after the 3rd and 4th
year." Yes, that's it.
New wells need to be drilled every 2 or 3
years, so the total stockpile
is far from negligible. We see that
this is restarting production somewhat
in the United States, but...  So, you're looking at
something with a 4,
5, or 6-year horizon in terms of reserves, and what's
rarely discussed is that this boom has a
consequence: it's caused
the price of gas to plummet. People say it's
great that the United States has cheap gas, but there's
a small problem:
now the oil companies are selling at a
loss, a huge loss. In other words, they're not drilling any
more wells to
raise prices. So, by the end of
2013 or the beginning of 2014, you're going to see
a collapse in
production, which will cause
the price to rise sharply to
profitability levels. Therefore, there will be SOPs and
Gos that will last throughout the entire
period, given the
specific nature of shale gas. One last
point is that they obviously
started drilling where it's
easiest, so as time goes on—
2015, 2016, 2017—they'll have to go looking for
areas that are much less
profitable and much more expensive to produce.
So, it's interesting.
Finally, there's a kind of small
cloud of smoke over almost soon, it's
Saudi Arabia, and then in
2030 they  They're going to exploit the entire planet, which
is completely false given the simple
geological capabilities of the United States,
sir. The market is bouncing
back, a bubble, a bubble, as usual, with,
as Olivier said, a price that
was $12 in 2008. We know
they have an
$8
extraction cost; today it's worth $3.60,
so it's quite simple: they lose $
4.40 per unit. So there you have it, at this
rate...
First, you had the
American majors who went into this
business, and they could compensate with the
more
classic things you had. I
agree, the Americans exploited a
vein, and as always, they
magnified it because that's their
style.
But in 10 years, I don't see what will
happen in 3 or 4 years, but in
10 years, it's a vein that will be very
wide,
yes, it holds true, even saying... well, I mean,
today we're in the second
phase, meaning that you have...
Major companies that paid
exorbitant prices to acquire land and so on, expecting to
make money, realized
they were losing as much as they anticipated.
Now they're trying to
perpetuate the myth, trying to
offload it to followers, to
smaller companies, at not-too-bad prices
to get by. It's
the classic tactic, I mean, once
you've made a
bad investment, you try to
pass it on, so you don't want to say it's
bad. The unique thing about this is that it's not just about
style. It wasn't the major companies that went
looking for it; it was
companies
created specifically for this purpose that acquired the
rights. These companies went public,
saying, "Look,
this is going to be fantastic!" They were then
bought out by the major companies
3 or 4 years ago. These major companies are now
experiencing tens of billions in
losses on their acquisitions,
but it's all been used to enrich those  who
sold the box first in a game of
good luck, indeed you now have
rights which, moreover, are being depleted
because when they don't exploit
the wells, they lose
the rights. It's very complicated, Philippe. I
would like you to talk to us about
derivatives on this extraordinary financial market. What
can you
tell us about derivatives,
the volume of perhaps the possible
threats they represent to our
economy, especially the
American economy? Listen, I'm going to talk about
commodity derivatives
since we were discussing the subject.
Everyone still remembers the big
speculative bubbles, especially the
2008 oil bubble.
Imagine also that
gold derivatives represent a
huge market, or silver and so on.
Derivatives markets on gold and silver.
Can you specify? Yes, these are
futures, options, certificates,
certificates that are possibly
convertible into physical metal. Don't be
fooled, because
most often those who tell you it's
convertible don't have...  As we
saw recently in
Hong Kong at the beginning of the summer, an
intermediary offered the
possibility of converting stocks. And the day
people came, because
they wanted pH Global—well, no, no, it's
in Hong Kong, MF Global—it went
bankrupt because they
speculated in a completely
unreasonable and
disproportionate way. So the Hong
Kong company, whose name escapes me,
completely stopped everything, decided to
halt its activities, unable to
deliver the physical stock. And we were, I
tell you, dealing with derivatives, which
are quite marginal compared to currency
derivatives and
debt derivatives. So today, if we rely on the
figures from the valuation,
we're between 730,000 and
750,000 billion in
derivatives of all kinds, knowing—I need to
sit down here—that
605 to 70% of derivatives are
debt derivatives in all their forms, including
government debt.  Uh,
mortgage debt,
high debt, so high debt in all its forms:
corporate debt, municipal debt,
which has already been mentioned, and so on. So roughly speaking,
if you want the total of
debt derivatives, credit,
auto loans, whatever you
want, it's $500 trillion.
Well, the growth rate is quite
easy to calculate since we had fallen back to $
445 trillion in derivatives in March
2009. So, 4 years and 6 months later, we
're at $730 trillion, $750 trillion. If we
continue at exactly the same
pace, it's easy. We aggregate the
injections from the Bank of
England, the Bank of Japan, and the United States, which gives
us around
$150 billion per month.
So it's easy, right? That's $5
billion per day.
All of this is invested at 70% or even 80% in currency
derivatives, credit, and
debt. In July 2014, we will
probably have  It has reached a current level of 1
trillion in derivatives, so what does that
actually represent for banks and all those
who invest in these products? It's
something in the order of 30
trillion. That means we're talking about
leverage of 25. You have to
realize what leverage of
25 is. That's very, very good to know. And
for example, for
French banks or many
American investment banks, their outstanding
loans are leveraged at 40 or even higher,
up to 60 in Germany for
commercial banks. So, these
figures are truly
staggering,
incomprehensible to an individual. And
I just wanted to
clarify before handing over the floor why we're using
this kind of leverage of 30, 40, 50. Because
if we don't multiply
these virtual debt purchases, we won't be
able to maintain rates at their current level, that is,
2.75 on typical American bonds.  At
75 on
Dubound 2 ET5i, on average in Europe,
these leverage ratios allow for a
plethora of money to
distort the price of debt, the
true price of debt. Therefore, there are both
absolutely
staggering leverage ratios and, on the other hand, another
phenomenon, which is, of course, the dispossession of
debt holders.
Could you democratize this information a bit more
regarding the volume
of derivative products?
Could you then move on to the interest rates,
the threats they represent, and the
position of the different banks? Everyone
who uses a bank knows that there are
two types of banks: the bank that
has liquidity and makes loans, and
then there is the bank that takes on
commitments, which in banking jargon
are called off-balance-sheet commitments. But these are
commitments that, until 15 years ago, the
total assets and liabilities should not
exceed 8 to 12 times equity.
We have reached a point where,
thanks to off-balance-sheet items, or because of them, the
bank's total equity ratio is now situated...  For the
best-managed banks, it's 20 to 1; for the
riskiest banks, it's 80 to 1. There's one
institution that at the end of 2012 had 76—
listen, it's not a CEORD, no, no,
we're not going to... So from there,
we can say that it should decrease,
okay? Why did it
increase? And not because of the banks,
only because of the governments. They
wanted to place the paper they needed quickly and cheaply. Okay, so
if this
bank-government mechanism changes, what
is the risk for the individual? The
first risk for the individual is
that, uh, uh, the banks
take on less, the governments
maintain
significant debt needs, and well, at that
point, rates rise. So if
rates rise, as one of us
rightly said, uh, you, the individual, will be
stimulated to
buy, but you, the individual, will
half cry, huh? These are people who
laugh, people who cry, because what
you invested, either directly or
in...  Pension funds will indeed
lose value if interest rates rise;
the value of what banks hold in
bonds falls. That's
basic financial arithmetic. So
the risk for all of us is that if
interest rates rise, the value of
pension funds and retirement funds
falls, the assets in which
you've invested become less
valuable, and your net worth,
meaning your personal wealth,
decreases. Do you have any
advice on how to protect oneself from this type of
movement? Listen, I can tell you what I've done
for myself: for eight years,
I haven't held a single stock, not a single investment, and
I've been holding cash.
So, I'm a
banker, so I'm extremely wary
of your colleagues—not
my colleagues—the system, the system, the system, the system. Okay,
Olivier, uh,
yes, perhaps we could elaborate on a couple of
points, perhaps we could be
a little more concrete about
derivatives. Uh, perhaps we should explain
Derivatives are basically
instruments that, in theory, are
supposed to act as
insurance against the various elements
we discussed earlier. They can
also be seen as bets, depending on how they're made.
But let's
imagine a currency derivative:
we'll place a bet on the
dollar's exchange rate in a year, and I
'll pay a small premium. If
the dollar rises above a certain level, I'll receive
money, and if it falls below,
I'll have lost, like with insurance.
So, it's a system that, fundamentally and
intellectually, is a very, very
sound system that
allows you to insure yourself, and therefore, in theory,
reduce risk. Because, obviously,
if I'm a European exporter, this is
a product that interests me because
I know the price in a year. That's somewhat equivalent to
knowing the dollar's price in
a year, or at least to having assumed that
you know the
dollar's price in a year. So, that's very good,
but the problem is that  It's been
completely diverted from that purpose,
and those who buy the products
are no longer people who are going to sell
products in the United States and
need financial insurance; they're
people making a bet, like you and
me. We just say, "Here, I'll give some
money, and if the dollar
goes up, well, I'll get some money back."
So, I'm making this bet. The
difference is that in the first case,
if I'm an exporter and things
go badly with the dollar, I'll
lose money, so I have a risk
of losing something. This
derivative product allowed me to insure myself against
that loss. When we switched to
betting mode, I no longer risk anything, regardless of
the dollar's level. In theory, whether it's
high or low, it doesn't cost me
anything. I'm just taking this bet. Basically,
like I'm betting on a Paris, it's
exactly the same thing. Olivier Philipp,
excuse me, Olivier Philipp, could
you follow up on what
Hervé and Olivier said, and
could you tell me a little bit about shadow
banking?  What this represents for
the US economy and the
global economy... don't fight to
speak, I'll just pick up on what
Olivier just said. One point to
clarify is that many of these
bets on bond products are
quite typically
fixed-rate/variable-rate arbitrage opportunities with a term of 3, 5, or 10
years, depending on the maturities
available on the market.
But we're seeing
the same kind of bubble reforming as in
2005, 2006, and 2007 with subprime mortgages. We're simply
recreating them.
We're creating
derivatives of
real estate loans or mortgage receivables from scratch. And it's
not just in the United States; we're
finding them almost everywhere now. We're
also recreating auto loan derivatives.
Anyway, we haven't
learned the lessons of 2007, 2008,
and we've gone right back to the drawing board,
explaining that
ultimately, regardless of the size of the outstanding amount, even a
million...  billions at the end of
2014, but in any case, the system is
stable since all these bets are
insured bets. There are those who
take risks, and others who
offer to insure them, and everyone
agrees that it should
work. There are those who want
risk, and there are those who want to hedge
against risk, so it can be done
almost infinitely. The problem is that, as we
saw in 2008, insurers
absolutely do not have the means to
fulfill their obligations when things go wrong. But
today, we continue to pretend that
this time it will go well, and
given the size of the outstanding balance, which is
a variation of only 0.3% of the
total amount down, for example, it is enough to
cause gigantic losses,
and with a 3% decrease in the value of the
total outstanding balance, most banks have nothing left on their
balance sheets; their equity is
literally razed to the ground. And what we
know in addition to that is that with the
power of computer technology,
when the  Things have started to
deflate, everything is going to happen
extremely
fast. I would say we're in a
situation that is much
worse than that of 2008 because, on top of everything else, we think we're
protected. That is to say, I
think the bankers have
the impression that
regulations and constraints have been imposed on them, so that
now we have a good understanding of
risk and that we no longer risk anything.
We see this in what is still rather appalling.
We see today that
equity capital and ratios
are
always determined with the same
method, that is to say, when you have a
sovereign country, it's not a
risk, so you don't need to
put equity capital against it. When you
have something that is rated by our
dear rating agencies, which have failed miserably for
years by giving us subprime,
triple-A rated bonds and so on, well, it's still
astounding not to
understand that these people are
useless by definition and based  A
risk system like that is completely
insane, yet we happily continue.
That is to say, if you have a standard rating, or
something like a double A or triple A, well, there aren't
many triple A's anymore, there's only
Landouillette which is at 5A,
but below that there's not much.
But you still have
triple A's and double A's today, and
these are considered
unshakeable and not worth
putting any equity capital in their place.
So you think you're protected, you
think there have been regulations, you
think things have been
put in place since 2008. In fact,
not at all. So we continue
exactly as before, with the added bonus of a
considerably increased amount of money, which
means that now things
are so tense that the slightest, the tiniest little speck of
dust in there can
end very, very badly. Philippe, yeah,
I
just wanted to give a little answer about
shadow banking. So this shadow
banking, well, it's
often made up of...  Over-the-counter (OTC) transactions
between institutions,
often between
institutions based in the
United States or Europe, are unlisted. Is there
diplomatic control,
legislative control over shadow
banking? Do states,
ministers, or
our government have effective
operational oversight of shadow banking? It's such a
vast subject, I think we'll come back to it,
but I just wanted to focus on
this specific topic of
shadow banking. So, the principle
is indeed concluding
OTC transactions between an
institution in a country with
oversight and offshore countries where it doesn't
exist. And why hasn't this shadow
banking been
restricted or regulated at all since 2008? Well,
simply because we've only taken half-
measures. We created a Volker rule
that isn't applied properly;
it's almost devoid of substance
today. But this Volker rule has
led institutions
to create subsidiaries in such a way that
none  One of them doesn't exceed a
certain critical size that
requires it to declare its activities. So
before, I had my investment banking division,
for example, which generated 50
billion in revenue.
Now I have 10 investment banking subsidiaries,
each generating 5 billion,
which are not regulated. So we
circumvent shadow banking. And then we
learned yesterday—I'll go back in
time—it was on November 17th or 18th
that the Fed decided to postpone by one year
the implementation of the Volker rule
as it existed and was designed
for July 2014. It will be pushed back to
2015, but with intense lobbying from the
banks, we can expect that
this Volker rule, which is in effect by July 2015, will be
completely devoid of substance, with no
effectiveness or
binding value. Hervé
Olivier
[Music]
Go ahead, the reality, the reality is
threefold. The first is that there is an
immense amount of capital that does
n't generate  That
increasing and that this flow of
capital is very good, but it's not by
placing the money in banks
that will have the minimum return, so
they do
shadow
banking outside of banking rules.
That is to say, they have teams
of men who lend to this
company, lend to this individual,
invest without bank control. That's the
first point. The second point is that
the banks are no longer able to
control why, but you have to read
Bernardke's book on the
1930-38 crisis where he says the main reason for
the crisis wasn't
1929, it was the fact that from 1932 onwards the
banks laid off thousands of
commercial bankers capable of making
loans, and when we wanted to
restart these bankers, like the son,
like the father of the CEO of the
bank when I was young, had become a
taxi driver, so he hadn't been in
banking for 15 years. Well, the
third point is that the reality of the
risk is  Hidden at every level,
right? The banks have
very significant internal losses that they don't
show. The central bank does
n't demand transparency. The bodies
responsible for conducting audits say
even less, and the general management remains silent
in every language. So,
if we take the remarks that have just been
made and this
very characteristic context of a lack of
information, a fierce desire on the part of the
leaders to continue making
fortunes, a lack of control, and
general hypocrisy, we see that we
are in a risky environment with
players
who will do things contrary to
the general interest. Olivier, it's
difficult to bounce back after that, though.
The diagnosis is absolutely, absolutely accurate
and absolutely
lucid. So indeed, it's scandalous that we did
nothing serious after
2008, when in September 2008, I think
all the bankers on the planet were sweating bullets,
saying everyone
understood that we were not very
far from a general collapse. We did
nothing serious. It's...  It's
really just a
patchwork solution, and even then, some
measures will arrive in 5  Or 10 years,
and we haven't done anything, and it's worse than
before. I'm going to give you a
small figure about currencies, about
exchange markets on the
planet, to make
things a bit more tangible. There are 70
billion exports every day on the planet,
right? 70 billion is sold, so it's exchanged.
So we can say that if we
wanted to insure ourselves, especially, well, it would cost
70 billion
in insurance, and I'm
not even taking into account the fact that it's
often done in the same currency, in euros or
dollars. But to give you an idea of ​​the scale,
it would perhaps be at most 70
billion every day on the planet.
In 2007, 3 trillion
dollars changed hands. So obviously, most of it was
just people betting on
the yen, right Philippe? We bet on the yen,
tomorrow it goes up, tomorrow it goes down. Here, I'll
give you some money, we'll see what
happens. It was 3 trillion per day in
In 2007, by 2010 it had gone up to 4
trillion per day, and we just got the
figure for 2013: 5.2 trillion per day.
So obviously, exports haven't
changed much. So we
see that we have a system that is indeed overflowing with
money, we don't know
what to do with it, and so we make bets,
we make bets. As long as everything is going
well, as Philippe also said,
we can make
derivatives, we can make loads of them, it inflates, it
inflates, it inflates. Yes, there's always
someone solid on the other side, there's no
problem. All it takes is for one of them to
fall for everything to collapse.
We didn't do much in 2008.
The only reaction from the G20 was to
make a list of
systemic banks. The G20 made a list,
saying, "We have a first list of 29, I think,
or 30. These are the 30 banks on the
planet. We've identified them, the
names are there. So if a bank falls, there
A global cataclysm risks
dragging all the other banks down
with it, and therefore all the economies
that are actually linked to banks.
Faced with that, what do we do? Well, maybe we'll
put in a little more
capital, we'll see. But the question of
how we can accept the existence of a
structure, the existence of a
systemic bank, how can we intellectually accept that
when it would be enough to
cut the bank into four or four, without
even resorting to drastic measures, to
say we'll reduce the size,
the risk of theft
rolls, yes,
ENF, so more robust
rolls. Morgan or Goldman think that's
not, it's really not
the happiness of grandeur. In any case,
the idea is there. In France, we had five
systemic banks, we're
practically at zero. The United States,
first of all, has as many as England. They
had five, well, they only have four now,
rest assured. Dexia has just been removed from
the list for the reasons you
know. Well, we might indeed reach
zero. There's only one left in
Germany, which already...  This is causing a lot
of concern for the Germans. Why do we have
four times as many as the Germans?
Why aren't we being told, "Hey, in this case,
Germany is perhaps
a model to follow." Having only one
systemic bank... we see that we're
not asking these questions. The main issue is
how not to question the
system when we know—you don't
need to be a Trotskyist—that it's
dangerous, it's incredibly dangerous.
Why aren't we capable of demanding
the same level of financial security
as we demand nuclear security, even though
the risks are of the
same order of magnitude? Regarding
risk perception, we saw with
Edward Snowden's leaks that the
American state tries to anticipate
risks at all costs, even if it means flouting
the constitution and the
founding principles, and especially its allies.
I would like to have your
reaction, RV, on the predatory
behavior in
intelligence gathering, whether in
the banking sector or
the economic sector. What do
you think?  From a
personal and,
more
professionally, perspective, let's
start with an observation:
the ability to track all
financial movements is the result of a
series of technological revolutions,
and we're not going to dwell on that.
We can say it's immoral that things are this way.
I was an executive accountant
at a British bank that
created the mechanism for controlling all
financial flows entering and
leaving Europe,
and we were forced by
European central banks to hand over
our daily files to the Americans.
So, what year was this?
Fifteen years ago, we would report
every night to
Washington, to
the SEC, or to
Washington, or the executive branch—I don't
know exactly, I can't invent what
I don't know. What
I do know is that all these
financial movements affecting Europe and
the rest of the world were shared
with the Americans, and the argument given to
us was that we
had to seize the money.  The money
from the father and so on,
well, I don't see this situation
changing. Do I find it
morally reprehensible? It's an
obvious limit
to a
sad hold on our private lives, but
it is, right? And we come to a
second point, which is that it is
because the balance of power
between the United States and Europe is
not strengthening significantly in
Europe's favor. Philippe, regarding
predictive behavior on
financial flows, what can you
tell us? Is hyper-frequency trading
blocked by
NSA algorithms? Has the NSA become the cutting edge
of
predictive behavior for the American financial system?
I think that today the
most successful and
innovative researchers... certainly, there are a
number of them working for the NSA.
I think that Goldman Sachs and JP Morgan
also have a breeding ground of
very innovative and highly skilled researchers.
Regarding espionage, we seem to have
completely forgotten that about ten
years ago, there was an
echelon that spied on us from the cutting
edge.  From the court, no, finally, which
spied on all
telephone conversations, emails... well, now we
see that Prism is simply a bit
more efficient, right? With the law of May,
I imagine they have a much, much
higher coverage rate
today.
In fact, for a long time now,
and at a certain level, there has been a
collaborative behavior between the
American,
French, and
Israeli intelligence services. So obviously, there's no
obvious collaboration with the
Russians or the Chinese, who, on the other hand,
might be in a system
of exchange. Well, everyone is
spying on absolutely everyone else. We
find that immoral or not, that's how it is. What
can you
tell us about that? I'll simply respond
to what Mr. de Carmois
said: it's been going on for 15 years,
probably even much longer than 15
years, and we seem to be discovering it
today, as usual. That is to say,
the French are shouting their heads
off, saying, "But it's not possible!"  Are the
Americans spying on us? Yes, they've been spying on us
since
the war. What does that mean
to
you in particular? Well, personally, not having
much to hide, I don't really care,
but it's just not very
pleasant to think that they can
listen to your conversations and that they can... well,
now they can also have some
fun and every time you answer the
phone, say "terrorist," and so
on, because it works on
algorithms, and so you'll be
listened to and then throw a
number of stupid things at them. But I mean, it's
very unpleasant, period.
Now, I don't have any
state secrets, and so personally, if they
listen to me, they won't learn
much they don't already know.
So, Olivier Berer, I'd like your
opinion on the Transatlantic Trade and Investment Partnership (TTIP) on this
point. I'd like to
respond, I know it's
something quite terrifying
when you look at it. In just a few
years, obviously, the principle is the same old
trick of spying here and there,
but this...  What has really changed is
the capabilities. They
now have the capacity
to record 100% of all
telephone communications that have
passed through the country and to archive them
easily. Obviously, the NSA is at the
forefront of this. The
reactions, both European and
French, have been very interesting at this
level. We saw that fairly quickly there were
purely symbolic protests
because, of course, the
French government is doing something similar, probably much
less effectively, much to its
regret, because it doesn't yet have the
capabilities. We know very well that this kind of
practice is also being carried out
in France.
So, we can say, indeed, well,
ultimately, it's true, secrets are
unpleasant, I confirm that today,
today, that's my concern. It's
not, obviously, immoral, but well, strictly speaking,
we can say moral, where we are
in our society today, but it's
dangerous, it's dangerous.
I'd like to finish on this point.
Dangerous, what happens if, as is somewhat the
case right now, we enter into
less and less democratic regimes? What
would have happened in
1940? Jean Moulin's Facebook, I think it was
interesting for quite a few
people to have. And it's true that we're also at a
stage where we see that it's not just a matter of banning it, it's
really possible. And if we
take a step back, it's quite sad
because we realize that
systematically,
you give humankind a little something and they'll get their
hands on it. So obviously, at
first, it will be to fight against
terrorism and barbarians,
but well, we still record
100% of communications, you never know.
And you have this on many
subjects, you have this obviously, so here in
computer science, you have it in
biology right now, researchers
are tinkering with the
smallpox virus because sometimes you
never know, you give
nuclear energy quickly, we do
Nuclear bombs, well, for the moment it hasn't
gone too badly, except for
Japan. What will the consequences be in
300 or 400 years? We won't be around to see it.
But we can also be worried
about this inability to say, "Let's try
to be a little more cautious and
reasonable." I would even say that the
NSA is the tree that hides the
forest, in a way, since there are 14
American intelligence agencies that spy on us.
They all have their own
specific areas of focus. It's bad luck if they do something.
So, among these
agencies that spy on us,
some are indeed involved in
economic intelligence, so they try
to find out who is trying to sign
contracts with whom. There are those that
purely spy on patents, some that
spy on financial transactions, and some that
try to collect
intelligence on all
opaque finance. But remember this
number: 14 intelligence agencies. The
NSA is just the largest, but
each one has its own field
of investigation, with its own...  Two
little scandals just to finish, two
rants: one against England,
which I believe is part of
the European Union and is the gateway to the United
States for spying on
all the transatlantic cables that
pass through its territory. How can we accept that a
country in the European Union spies on
other countries, not for
terrorism, but really for
economic espionage, mainly because they prefer that we
export
stale or corrupted information? Yes, that
must be it, that must be it. So, bravo to the
European Union! Secondly, Edward
Snowden, thanks to whom we
learned a lot, and Povga is in
Moscow. They refuse him political asylum so as
not to displease the United States, and we were still very close to shooting down the
president's plane. What was it?
Bolivian, I think, I believe,
because maybe, maybe he was on it. It's still sheer madness,
and we're doing everything
to discourage whistleblowers.  There are
whistleblowers, and Japan has just introduced
a law to punish them, so there's
something that I find
worrying: the
totalitarian drift in all countries.
That is to say, today we're in
a situation where
states are backed into a corner, with their backs to the
wall. Why? Because they have a
debt they don't know how to
cancel, reduce, or get out of.
They no longer have growth ahead of them,
and today they're backed into a corner.
And when it's exactly like when
you wound an animal while hunting, it
becomes very
dangerous. And here we are today
with a denial of European democracy,
but that's been going on for a few years now. And we're in a
state that's drifting away from the system, no longer
respected
because it's no longer
respectable, and it's drifting
dangerously. So it's true
that now, with the means they
have, it risks being  It's a bit
complicated for us, with some
pretty unimaginable things. When you see
that the Guardian, which collected
all of Snowden's data, was
forced in England to destroy the
hard drives, the police even came to the
Guardian to verify that
he was indeed destroying the drives containing
Snowden's information with a hammer. What's more, he said he had copied it
abroad, but they must have thought twice.
England, the
country of Vasily Supremacy,
asked a newspaper to destroy
hard drives containing information about
the United States. I have a question
for Hervé. You were
Vice-President of the
Trilateral Commission. You just returned from Krakow, if
my memory serves me right. You
participated in the Trilateral Commission
recently. Without giving away any secrets, what
can you
tell us about the
Trilateral Commission's perception of what's happening in the
United States, about the American economy?
What are its recommendations? And please,
go ahead.  The
recommendation, I would say, from almost all
Trilateral Commission countries in Europe and Asia, is
more Europe, more Europe,
meaning a stronger, more
structured Europe in the
financial field, one that can take
measures to ensure
long-term European growth.
Many European and
Asian countries feel that our
transformation towards unification and
action within the
European Community has slowed considerably.
Secondly, they don't
think it will
accelerate. They believe that with a
very reluctant England and the ambiguous
American stance—which, let's remember, is at the
origin of the
European movement—Jean Menet
worked for 25 years in the United States, so it's important to remember that.
They are at
the origin, but when they see Europe
developing as one of the major drivers of
American power,
they
have behaviors where they are happy for
Europe to develop, but...  A
rhythm that allows them to preserve their
preeminence, Mr. Béchade, Mr. de la
Marche, and Mr. Beruer. What
can you tell us about this supposed
guardian of our problems, this supposed
advisor to our leaders? What opinion do
you have of the S tanks at the moment?
If you have a S tank you recommend, or
if you have a S tank that has made PR campaigns
that have
completely failed, well,
about the S tanks, I have
nothing to say. I would have to say something about
the S tanks. I would already have to say about the
few advisors of
successive governments who
seem to me
very deficient, let's say, to avoid
saying anything else, deficient in
relation to their perception or
in relation to everything. Well, we still have
people who hang around
the circles of power and who have failed every
time they have been in a
company. I won't mention his name, but
he is... and who delivers his
thoughts that interest no one except himself.
Maybe for years and
years, so, well, I mean, and
today, when we see
the actions being taken
by our government, we can't really say that we're
following a
very intelligent path. So, well, you could
say to me, regarding Europe,
this debate is interesting. Unfortunately, I
tend to think that all the
neoliberal excesses since the
1980s have killed the European project because
the European project has now become
synonymous with
hyper-financialization, with the Troika, with
major tension
between peoples, and that's what led to
the failure of the current euro.
It will undoubtedly be the final nail in the coffin,
and it's a shame to have transformed what was
originally a rather interesting idea
of ​​reasonable and
constructive cooperation between European countries
into a
project, certainly driven initially by the United States,
but undoubtedly a
very distorted vision. Did they try
to apply their own
European model, which doesn't really have much to do with
saying, "We're going to create the United
States of Europe." We're all  It's the same with
a German, a Spaniard, a Frenchman—
what cultural difference is there? None at all. So
we can unify all of that and make a single
country, and since we're at it, we'll create a
single currency with additional strategies.
Some players have
clearly stated this, saying in the
80s that Europe wasn't progressing anymore,
so we're not going to do
what we did for the United States
of Europe. Well, let's create a
single currency because we know very well that it will cause
problems after 10 or 15
years, and then people will have no
choice. They'll be forced
to go and create our United
States of Europe, without seeing that
it could also fail
miserably, which is still the
direction we're
heading in, with an
inconsistency that I find quite
criminal because ultimately what's happening
is a resurgence
of nationalism, obviously. If on
such a sensitive subject, with the excesses
that have occurred in the past regarding
nations, you manage to try
to lump everything together  Well, contrary to the
popular will, things aren't
progressing much in Europe. The latest
poll asked if you want more
Europe: 19% said yes, and it's fairly evenly split between
left and right. It's certainly not
a better way to move
the issue forward. So the question is, how are
we going to manage to undo the
mistakes that have been made without throwing everything away,
without throwing the baby out with the Dubai issue?
How do we ensure that we still
maintain the main point, which is
a minimum of cooperation and understanding
in Europe?
We can clearly see that we have
leaders who are not ready at all.
To backtrack, to return to
a powerful Europe, a Europe with
real policies, a Europe that builds, not
a Europe
that today forbids the creation of Airbus, just as
today it tries to create a
competing public company, an
American company, and then we'll talk about it again.
It's obviously completely
forbidden to create a Eurosoft to
compete with Microsoft so that we have an
open-source tool to manage our computers, so we know,
for example, if the American president does
n't have a button to shut down all the
Windows machines on the planet—it's called a
kill switch. Yes, these are
topics, questions, and yet we don't talk about them.
And even if we did
talk about them, it's forbidden in
the European treaties. We've enshrined in the
European treaties
the free movement of capital,
which is heresy. It's inevitably
something that will ultimately lead to the inability to
govern a country, since you'll have
the threat of the
financial markets anyway. Free
movement of capital, which is
invested, yes, very well, but what about the
speculative capital we've been talking about for
a while now?  They can come in the
morning and leave again an hour later,
having destabilized the system. This is completely
unacceptable. And what do we have written
in the treaties? Not only is that there, but
unanimity is required to reverse course. It's written
in the
Lisbon Treaty: unanimity is required to
reverse the free
movement of capital. The freedom of
people? No, there's no problem there.
The freedom of capital is clear, it's in black
and white. Look, there's a nice
article on that, Mr. de Carmois.
I would like to have your opinion
on the integrity of elected
legislative power in the face of banks. Do
you think our states are
sufficiently equipped to
resist and impose their will for
the common good against an
extremist banking lobby that is running away on cavalry? What
can you tell us about
the measures to be taken to strengthen
the state and its integrity in relation to the
decisions made on this
very
complicated earth? We need to see if there is
a common language, that is to say, a
common objective. And if we take as a
hypothesis that  The common goal in the
United States and Europe, for all
governments, right or left,
is economic growth. If
we take that as a given, then we have to
ask ourselves
if the banks are playing their role. If the
states are playing their role, then for
banks to be able to play their role, they need both
capital and personnel to
invest in SMEs,
growing businesses, and individual
entrepreneurs.
Currently, the banks aren't doing this.
Why aren't they? Because they've
absorbed
colossal amounts of government debt—not just from
states in good shape like Germany,
but from states that are struggling. And
the states completely control the
banks' balance sheets, and we don't realize this. The
best thing that could happen
to the banks is for the states to tell them, "
Listen, we'll buy you out and
finance all your government
debt elsewhere, and we'll force you
to go back to banking." In other
words, what exactly is
banking? This is the
second measure I'm asking you to do.  I would recommend that
your equity capital, relative to all your on- and off-balance-sheet
liabilities,
not exceed 12 to 1.
This will imply, gentlemen, that you will have to reduce your staff and redeploy
your personnel. You will recruit new
teams to provide credit to
the economy, something the State doesn't really know how to
do. I'll give you just one example:
the difficulty it has in getting off the ground with the
public
investment bank. Mr. Béchad, what
can you tell us about
the capacity to implement this type of measure given the
amount of money—I would
say fictitious or derivative money—do you
think that States are capable of
implementing this? Is it
realistic given the mountain
we have accumulated over these years?
I think everyone around
this table understands that since
2008, any attempt at
regulation has been systematically
torpedoed, both in the
American Congress and in Brussels. Torpedoed by
whom? Well, by those who actually
want to continue acting as if they were  To behave
as before the crisis, wanting to
continue making a lot of money
very quickly on products that have no
real economic utility, and the
banking profession is something
that is almost
soporific; we invest for the very long
term with
sometimes quite uncertain returns on investment. It's all in the
details, it's very, very
laborious. Whereas if some
genius has found a new magic bullet,
a new algorithm that allows them to
capture a large
spread on some debt derivative in a few hours, well,
obviously,
priority goes to that kind of operation. We were
talking earlier about S tanks;
today we'll say that the
realized utopia is that of
liberalism inspired by the
Austrian school, except that we've
recast it all in a sauce
of ultraliberalism and a total lack of
control. So we've completely
perverted the thinking of the Austrian-
Montpellier school. All of this was then taken up
and reconfigured by the Chicago school,
carried all the way to Washington by the Bank  The
American central bank, therefore, through all the
networks of influence dependent on the Chicago School, has
established a system in which a
few operators are completely at ease within
very large
investment banks, notably Goldman
Sachs, the elite of the elite in financial thought and
expertise, which provides
practically one out of every two US Secretaries of State, which
provides central bankers, including
Marc Carnet in England,
Vice President of the Reserve Bank
of Australia, and all the members of this group, have either at some point spent part
of their career
in a large investment bank or have worked at
universities where the prevailing school of thought is the one
we know, the one that
imposes a single way of thinking. So today,
to get out of this, for states to
regain control, and as
Mr. Garnois said, for
states to take back their debts from the banks
and, in fact, regain some
control and freedom, because the
bankers, the creditors,
obviously hold the reins.
borrowers, and I think that in all of
this there is no chance involved when there is so much
money at stake, it's never chance.
So I think that the banks, or at least
some of them, think that they
perhaps have a divine mission, that they are
perhaps fulfilling God's work. Those who
might think that, well, those who don't actually
think that,
they are fulfilling God's
work.
I'll cut you off on the subject of God's work... uh,
I have a question, to move from one thing
to another, I would like to ask you a
question that may seem
surreal to you: do
you think that the
extraordinary behavior that some
traders or some
trading floors have exhibited... can you
tell us if you are in favor of
drug control in trading floors
to prevent
fund managers or trading floor managers from
taking too many risks?
I'll tell you, it's common
knowledge that there is a lot of
cocaine circulating in the...
Trading floors, are you in
favor of testing
traders and
bank directors for drugs, like airline pilots? Let's
test everyone because
sometimes when we hear
Mr. Bernard's speeches, we wonder if he's been smoking something.
So why not? But if he had been
smoking something, he wouldn't be in that
position.
You have many people about whom
we can ask many questions,
so if we had to test everyone, we would
spend all our time doing that.
You can also test the
President of the Republic and his Minister
of the Economy because sometimes they give
speeches that are more than
curious,
so we can wonder if they have taken
illicit substances or not. Mr.
Bernard, yes, of
course, but that's what
I told you. I have a very
strong conviction that we should apply
the same standards to the financial industry
as to the nuclear industry, and in
particular, given what is happening and given the
risks taken by
market operators, it would seem to me to be a very
good idea.  A very good initiative. I'd like to
make a small observation:
we've been talking for two hours now about the
diagnosis of the crisis,
analyses that aren't all that
different, which isn't very surprising
because, moreover, I tend to
think that you don't have to be
very intelligent to understand what's
happening; you just need a little
intellectual honesty and to look at
the details, not to be lulled to sleep by
the sirens. I
was quite struck by Hervé's remarks
because I think it's the
first time we've seen a banker of
this stature make such statements in French. We're
not used to hearing this in
France. In the Anglo-Saxon world, many
have said it: former CEOs of Citigroup,
all those who worked to dismantle the
class, former presidents of Morgan Stan,
you can give me a list like that of about
twenty people of
Hervé's stature who speak about it in France. Why do
we never hear a former banker make such
harsh statements? It's
already a real  My question is, I'd like to
ask RV because, well, we're making a
diagnosis, which is good, and we might talk about possible
solutions later.
My question is, why isn't it being
implemented? That's what I'd like to know:
your perspective. Why, I
repeat, this perspective where all the
bankers in 2008 had major
crises, thinking everything was going to collapse?
We've reached a point where we're not
capable of taking
measures, which, moreover, aren't even
spectacular. It's just a few points; it basically takes us back to
1980, right? When I was
born and when I was 10, there was only
one fixing per day on
the Paris Stock Exchange, and it seems to me that
the country wasn't doing too badly. It
even had three or three points of growth back then.
Today, it
seems unimaginable to say, after all, a
stock has a value for a
day, it's the same, it's an
accounting standard. Besides, I'm not sure it's not being
misused; we could imagine things.
So it's not a revolution,
imagine we're going to give a
triple dividend to shareholders who have held their shares for over 10
years. Why not this kind of simple idea?
We can't seem to implement
common-sense things that have already
been implemented in the past. Where does
the problem come from? What can we do
to change things? Otherwise, we can
talk, it'll collapse a second
time, and we'll be able to get together again,
saying, "We were right, friends." Well,
unfortunately, like in Cyprus, we have a
ruin for all savers. Oh well,
there is a common-
sense answer to move from this. We have, we can
say roughly, the same banking system, the
same organization within banks, with slight
variations in IT here and there.
In 2013, what about 2000, or 1980?
We haven't changed. Why haven't we
changed the internal organization of banks
in the last 30 years?
Take Renault, for example,
or Peugeot, for instance. They...  They are completely
transformed in the markets, in their
working methods, in their marketing,
and so on, because we don't recruit
at the top of the banks, people who
can lead change. We don't
recruit them; we recruit
remarkably intelligent people. We
recruit people who have attended
the Inspectorate of Finances or the Corps
of Mines, but who don't have all the
training that starts from the bottom up. You
have to start at the bottom to understand
how a bank employee works,
to understand how the small customer
reacts, and who, as they move up the hierarchy,
knows how to lead change.
First point, and why don't they
want to take it on? They don't
want to take it on for two reasons: the
essential part, 30 to 40% of the
banks' profits, comes from market activities,
and to regain
real profitability by reducing
market activities, it will be
necessary to thoroughly reorganize the
bank from top to bottom. And for that, you
have to learn and implement
field management. I have a
question regarding this
reorganization, Hervé, at the moment.  Don't
you
sincerely think we've passed the
point of no return for an overhaul of
this banking system? I'll
take the case of Fujima: we had
a first reactor that went up in flames, yes,
and the only measures we'll be
able to take are
palliative measures on a globalized banking system. Don't
you think this overhaul is
so important and so
profound that we lack the courage, and
that our political decision-makers lack the courage?
But it's never too late,
right? If we
listened to people from 55 to 60 years old in
1947 saying, "We'll never have a
French industry," I heard that
all my childhood. "No, no, because there won't be
a French industry,
we don't know how to create a
French industry." Well, very well, there have been
people who led, there have been great
industrialists, the workers' movement, and so on,
who have done that. So
today we need people who are assertive, who are
competent, and who
are ready to transform the
banks and experience.  that I experienced
in London where I took over a bank with
18 hierarchical levels—
18 hierarchical levels, huh? That's
colossal! It hadn't changed for
100 years, huh? Except that its staff had
doubled. Well, we did it. We have to
explain this
to the English, you know, we explained to them that
we had been the leading bank
100 years ago, we were 28th today, we gave ourselves
5 years to
become 10th, and we did it. So all of this is
a leadership problem, it's
not an intrinsic problem of the
bank, Mr. de la Marche. I think we already
missed a window
of opportunity, which was in 2008. When you
want to negotiate with someone, it's
better to be in a position of strength. So
today, what have we done? You
had banks that were sweating bullets,
as
Olivier said at that time. We
shouldn't have given them a choice; we
should have told them...  Listen, that's how it's going to
happen, and there's no other way.
You sign
at the bottom of the page, we'll take care
of filling it out. The governments didn't do it. The
governments pulled the
banks out of the water, they dried them up, they put them back in, and at that point
they summoned them to the Ministry of Finance and elsewhere, saying, "
Excuse me for
bothering you, could you...
make a gesture and... do what we're
asking?" What did
the banks respond at
that point? They simply
scared the leaders by saying, "Watch out,
if you bother us, we won't lend anymore." Okay. So, since
the whole system is based on
free money at
zero interest rates, which is the biggest
mistake you can make because it leads to
a systematic misallocation of assets,
and so it
always ends the same way, that is to say,
very
badly, and since the whole system is based on
debt and the issuance of
perpetual debt, you have a leader
who finds himself facing a...  The banker who
told him, "If you bother me, I won't lend anymore,"
panicked. He said, "Excuse me for bothering you.
You can come back." He could go back
to his office. So, as long as
this continues, and as long as we don't have
someone, as Mr. Tapis, a real tough guy, said,
who can
tell the banker, "No, it's this way and that's that," well, you'll always have the same problem. Nobody wanted to. Well, we saw that Olivier was very much at the forefront of this, on the banking reform. When Mr. Oua was told that
perhaps his balance sheet needed to be reduced, he said, "
But for me, market activities
represent 3% of my business, just like that,
or 2%, looking straight
into the eyes of the MP who said, 'Oh really?
I thought it was more, excuse me
for bothering you, sir,
for asking you the question.'
So, when you have someone who lies through his
teeth in front of an
MP who asks him a question, '
What do you want to do?' and that
you  You have the MP who, on top of everything else, on the
other side, backs down, saying, "Oh,
excuse me, I misunderstood." Well,
you can be sure things aren't going to move forward
now. We
really need a political decision, and we
really need someone who wants to implement it.
And for the moment,
apart from Mr.
Hollande's statements that his first
enemy was finance, it's remained just... yes,
I think they've become
friends,
and it's just been a statement.
You were at the BFM Awards last night.
Could you share some
information
you gave off the record about
Mr. Trich's statements? It was
very amusing. Of course, many
people will tell you, "Well, Mr.
Trich is retired anyway,
and what he said is completely irrelevant,"
but it was still quite
amusing. He said three
things: he said that, in his personal opinion,
he wanted us to return to a
fixed exchange rate system, which, coming from the former
head of the ECB, was quite
something.  The second
thing he said was quite interesting:
some people should still ask themselves
the question. Those who
see the recovery and the end of the crisis
could ask themselves questions, because
when all the central banks in the
world were using unconventional measures
at a frantic pace,
one could still wonder
if we were
truly out of the crisis. That was
for those who saw the crisis as behind
them, I suppose. And the
third interesting thing he said was,
for all those who are criticizing
the ECB today, saying that it isn't playing
the game of the BoJ, the
Bank of Japan, and the Fed—that is, running
the printing press
and doing successive rounds of quantitative easing—
he said, and I remind you, that for
some time now it's been an unlimited open
bar. Those are the words: unlimited open bar
at the European Central Bank
for banks that can come and
finance themselves in exchange for any kind of
nonsense, since we
regularly lower the levels of  quality of
collateral and that therefore now the
ECB looks
more like a garbage dump than
a central bank, Mr. Béchade,
yes, uh, the figures speak for themselves,
the ECB's balance sheet is larger than
the Fed's, well fortunately thanks to J  anet
yen there might be a chance that the
United States will regain the lead, but well,
Mr. Dragou, Dr. Mr. Dragou
is lying in
wait, provided he gets the green light
from Carl Schou's Constitutional Court
for indeed limited limits that could
effectively be transformed into quantitative measures. Well, we're not
out of the woods yet, obviously.
Regarding the impossibility of
reforming the system, well, I think it's
quite clear: we have what we call
inbreeding and collusion,
inbreeding between bankers and
very high-ranking advisors, which we find
not only at Berry, since there,
indeed, between the Inspectorate of
Finances, Polytechnique, and so on, we
find pretty much the same people in the United
States who haunt the corridors of
the White House. Every American Secretary of the
Treasury is flanked by
at least three or four advisors from either
Goldman Sachs or
Citigroup. And there's what we call
the revolving doors system.
That is to say, you spend a few years
in a bank, obviously in
senior management, not in the
lower ranks, and then you join the
management team. So it doesn't matter if they're
Republican or Democrat, or in
France, right-wing or left-wing;
governments come and go, banks
remain. So we have this kind of inbreeding, which will
soon be very common.
And then in the United States,
we have something much more openly accepted,
which is collusion. That is to say,
since a Supreme Court ruling
that now allows a company to
finance, quite openly, any
candidate—a sheriff at the
local level, a mayor, a congressman, a
governor, a senator—it's completely
transparent. And that, in fact, was
the excuse:
until now we had
opaque financing systems, we're going to clean all that up.
And now, well,
we'll know that such and such a candidate in an election is
wearing a K-Fried Chicken cap,
or a Hallyday Burton cap, or a
cap
supported by...  A few
influential Wall Street banks, so when you
have both inbreeding and collusion,
you can't reform the system. It's
not enough to have a utopia where you say you're going to be
able to change
things or create an institution like the
Trilateral Commission where you say you'll never see
a third world war again and
you'll contain the spread of communism, etc., on a
global scale. You do need
a utopia, and you need
people to carry it forward. But when all the
people in power come from
the same school of thought—Montpellier,
Chicago—who have all gone through the
same paths, who have all followed the same
routes—banking, investment banking, and
then, let's say, the trappings of power
or the privileges of the Republic—
well, when you're in that situation, I really don't see how you
can reform. So, two last words. We'll
finish with Olivier Beruet, and
then Hervé. You'll speak
to close this debate. Olivier, the
democratic problem is indeed a
major issue in what's happening.
We can  To illustrate this with the history of
the separation of
banking activities, I've seen it quite
closely. It's amusing, this idea of
simply saying, "Okay, we'll ask the
banks to split in two, to
do the same thing if they want,
but each on their own: one that will
lend to the real economy with a true
public service mission, and the other that
will be a bank, not one that will handle
insurance products or
derivatives, as we were talking about. In
any case, we'll make sure they don't
contaminate each other." This vision
of separation is what existed in
France between 1945 and, in practice, 1995. It
was the rule in our economy.
Since 1995, in practice, we've changed that,
so we put the risks together, and in
ten years, it went bankrupt. So it's still
a great model. When we say we
have to separate, who says that today? You
have pretty much all the Nobel laureates
in economics, right? Maurice de Stiglitz
said it, Felps said it.  Nicolas Bavrez, who was
Friedman's student, therefore left-wing,
says that we must
separate, so basically all
the world's economic intelligence says
we must do it. I haven't found a
Nobel laureate who says how
clever it is to mix everything up. You
have plenty of former bank bosses in
the Anglo-Saxon world who
say the same thing about universal banks.
We've seen it, we've tried it, but it's
too dangerous, we have to abandon it.
In France, if you do a survey
of bank executives, half of them
already say we must separate.
You have the Financial Times which
tells you, "We don't really like regulation,
but we can't mess around
or it will collapse." We have a system
like this which says, "There isn't a single voice
except for the bankers currently in office
who say we must keep the
current model." And in the end, we see that we don't do it,
we don't do it in
England, we don't do it in the United States,
we don't do it in France, we don't do it in
Spain.  It's not done in Italy, though.
A real question is why, in any case,
it increases the power of these networks,
these ways of thinking that
prevent any reform. And
then it's not about making
speeches about finance being the enemy;
it's about saying that finance isn't an enemy, it's
people doing
their jobs as best they can.
Unfortunately, there are no more
general rules, no more vision
of the common good, and so when everyone
follows their own small, self-interest, it doesn't create
collective well-being at all;
it creates bankruptcy, long-
term bankruptcy. The
final word is that we're talking about
money, and money is like the
language of the HES; it's the source of all goods
and all words. Well, if we
take France, we can say that
overall we've managed our
banking systems well; we've managed them better
than the rest of Europe,
certainly better than the
United States, and infinitely better than
Japan. So, we've generally had
a Bank of  France and its
bankers, who have been prudent, still
need to do what to continue
contributing to growth in
France and Europe:
reduce finance and
redirect internal resources, both
human and capital, towards
industrialization,
international trade, and investment. I
think that in France, there has been a growing
awareness
among bankers over the past five years that this is
their primary mission, which makes me
quite optimistic about the future of
French and
European banking. Very well,
society... I'm sorry, I didn't mean to
jump in, but I do
n't share the same view at all
that our bankers have
behaved well. Just look at Société
Générale in Faerkerverviel; they had a
SATER debacle once in 2008 (AIG counterparty), and
they almost collapsed a second time
in 2008. Dexia went bankrupt, and Crédit
Agricole lost a significant amount in the process.
Ask yourself why Greece has 100 trillion euros in
derivatives, while France has...
Four systemic banks, so that's it. Anyway,
I have a disagreement
here on this point regarding
the management of the relative banking system, you know.
We're not good or bad, we're
better than others. Please specify if
you want. Okay, uh,
I wish you an excellent day
and I hope to see you soon, and thank you.
[Music] There aren't
many guys like Kusa, this
incredible Adonis-like figure who, looking everyone
in the eye,
said, "I'm not lying, you can believe me,"
and so on. There was something about it: how
can we imagine that a politician would be
able to say, "No, no,
wait, the general interest is the
defense of fundamental freedoms.
Fundamental freedom is the defense of
privacy," and there's a
conflict there. It's impossible in France. The
problem is that the
movement is demonized; we simply forget that these are
people who prioritize
results over methods and who are
capable of gaining an
intimate knowledge of a system.